Speaker 1: So many of you will remember that
I've been giving good news about declining COVID
cases on the show in the United States, dating
back to really the first few days of September.
I've also been saying since late October that
decline is starting to slow down. And then we
got to well, the cases are now flat. They're no
longer declining. We don't know if this is an
inflection point and cases will start going back
up or if they'll stay flat or if they'll continue
on down. We don't know what will happen heading
into winter. We now have a modest but clear trend,
which is that cases in the United States are going
back up. And in fact, they've been on the upswing
since roughly Halloween, so close to a couple of
weeks and cases are now up in the United States,
just shy of about 10 percent per day.
We had gotten down to 71000 cases a day,
which is crazy to think that, wow, what if we
had a huge decline down to 71000 cases a day
that is now back up to 77000 cases a day? And this
is really, really not good. Now, if we were at the
point where cases no longer meant deaths, either
because enough vaccination has taken place where
most folks are protected against serious illness
and death, or because of a less deadly strain that
has evolved, this wouldn't be as bad, but those
things haven't happened yet. And so far, deaths
have been following cases by about three to four
weeks. And just as we saw cases stop their decline
three to four weeks ago, deaths are now flat.
Deaths are no longer declining. They're stuck
at about 1100 COVID deaths per day in the
United States. So there is every possibility
that we are at the beginning of a new spike and
a potentially very ugly winter. Now, maybe not.
Maybe not. We don't really know yet, but the case
increase has started and the death decline has
stopped. Now, often, as we've seen throughout
the pandemic, what happens in the United States
follows what happens in other parts of the world.
Part of the reason for that is that many of the
spikes are caused by variants, which we first
observe in other parts of the world, like Europe.
So far, the global numbers are not looking
particularly auspicious for the United States over
the next three months. Cases around the world are
up even more than in the United States. Globally,
cases had bottomed back. They'd bottomed out
at four hundred and three thousand cases a day.
Globally, cases are now up to four hundred seventy
two thousand cases a day. So while in the U.S.
cases are up nine or 10 percent, globally, cases
are up about 17 percent. That's not a great signal
for what is to come here as far as global deaths.
Those are slightly up. Global deaths had bottomed
out around 60 600 a day. Deaths are now back up
to 100 a day around the world. That's an increase
of about six or seven percent. So if there is
any good news to point to and even this, you'll
see why it's not even that great we can point
to hey, vaccinations every day are now climbing
in the United States. They're not incredible
numbers. Looking at the graph on the screen,
if you're watching today, you might see that daily
vaccinations really bottomed out in mid-July.
And then as Delta surged and discussion of Delta
surged, vaccinations also started to increase.
In late July, we were down to about 550000 doses a
day that has climbed and climbed, almost tripling.
And we're now doing over the last week about 1.3
million doses per day. Unfortunately, and this is
just horrible. The not so good thing is that the
increased doses per day are significantly driven
by people who already have two doses getting a
third dose. So you're not vaccinating that many
new people. If you ask the question how many
new people are getting vaccinated each day,
it might only be a couple hundred thousand to
maybe 300000, sadly. I mean, it's good that people
are getting third doses and more protection,
but a huge portion of the daily doses today.
Are people getting a third dose good for those
people? Not so good for the population at large.
Now that five to 11 year olds can start to get
vaccinated in the U.S., we do expect the number
of kids with one dose in that age group to be
at roughly a million. Right now, about a million
kids have already gotten vaccinated. That's good,
but the misinformation continues to kill people.
We have a report from Colorado from CBS Denver,
which says that according to a Colorado ICU nurse,
there are many COVID patients there in the ICU
with COVID. They don't believe the virus is real.
They believe the hospital made them sick, and
in some cases they called the nurses murderers.
So that's very bad. We will see what things
look like by Thanksgiving. I've started to get
questions from from some of you about what is my
Thanksgiving plan from the standpoint of medical,
from the standpoint of COVID. I'm going to be
doing a testing Thanksgiving. So it's going to be
maybe outdoor, maybe indoor, depending on the
weather. Everybody will be tested and I've
interviewed, everybody will be vaccinated and
tested. When we interviewed Vincent Racaniello
from Columbia University and I said to him,
Sir, is this foolproof if people get a test
right as they're going in? Is there any way
you might be incubating and contagious but
negative? And he basically said if you're
using the test for a few hours gathering,
it's essentially foolproof in the sense that this
was what he said. If you were incubating the virus
and you don't yet have symptoms and you test
negative, you're almost certainly not contagious
for the next few hours. So what you wouldn't want
to do because of this possibility that you've been
infected, you're incubating, but you don't yet
test positive. Don't use the test as justification
to hang out for a week without doing any more
testing, because then you might turn positive
and turn contagious. But if you're doing a
few hours gathering, Vincent Racaniello was
confident that if everybody has a negative
test, everybody's going to be not contagious,
at least for a few hours. So that's my plan for
Thanksgiving. I'm curious to hear about yours